a major conference will soon get
underway here in Berlin aimed at ending
years of conflict in Libya Germany says
its aim is to stop Libya from becoming a
second Syria and it's bringing together
the country's main warring parties and
their international allies at the
negotiating table right now Libya and
its backers are split between two rival
governments in Tripoli the UN backed
government afiya's al Siraj and in
Tobruk the Libyan National Army led by
general Khalifa Haftar Germany has
expressed confidence that an agreement
can be reached in the German capital but
few Libyans share their optimism a quiet
day in Libya's capital Tripoli Libyans
awaiting news of Sunday's Berlin peace
conference but expectations are low
regarding the Berlin conference if it
favors the Libyan people Libya will of
course welcome it but if it favors other
matters then we won't be happy the truth
is the conference of Berlin is simply a
trap the Libya I don't think that any
benefits will come out of it there are
currently two sides to Libya the
internationally recognized government
and the opposition spearheaded by this
man general Khalifa Haftar he wants to
take power and he's raised the stakes
forces supporting general hafta have
blocked oil exports from key ports in
eastern Libya holding the economy to
ransom the country is divided with an T
after protests in western libya the
conference in berlin overseen by the
United Nations aimed to bridge this
divide but it won't be easy I'm not so
pessimistic to say that Berlin will be
useless but I'm not so naive to say that
it will be the end of international
divisions if we can lighten regimes we
harmed down and qualify the divisions
especially the regional ones but also
international divisions that we have
seen in recent times
that would be very good 9 years of
conflict in Libya has slowly turned into
a regional proxy war the UN wants world
leaders to stop meddling and hopes the
Berlin conference will be the beginning
of the end for foreign interference
joining me now in the studio is a DW
political correspondent Hans Brandt
honza thanks for being here how crucial
are today's international peace talks
for Libya's future well obviously
there's no guarantee of success but I
think the main significance lies and the
fact that it is happening at all that
all these different players are being
brought to a single table sitting around
the same table in the same conference
room and discussing the future of Libya
discussing their rival interests in in
Libya and deciding how that can be
resolved how those interests can be
balanced out it's a very very complex
situation with a whole lot of different
players apart from the actual combatants
on the ground as it were
there's Russia on the one side Turkey on
the other side they are the United Arab
Emirates and Egypt on the one side
there's Qatar on the other side in fact
we have a little piece trying to explain
what exactly the different sides are
let's have a look at that strongman
general halifa hafta wants tripoli
together with his Libyan National Army
he hopes to capture the country's
capital and take full control of this
oil-rich nation and it's partly because
of oil that Russia and Turkey have waded
in on opposite sides of this conflict
with Turkey behind Faisal Suraj's UN
backed government and Russia supporting
hafte Moscow has denied reports it sent
mercenaries to reinforce the generals
fighters but on Thursday
turkey confirmed it had started
deploying troops to help al Siraj in
Tripoli despite a UN arms embargo
with Libya so unstable the fear of
resurgent Islamist terror has worried
many European countries but other
factors mean the EU is split over its
alliances officially the Tripoli based
government has the backing of Europe
including Germany but Italian Prime
Minister Gazette piccante met general
Hoffa earlier this month Rome sees him
as crucial in stemming the flow of
migrants across the Mediterranean and
Frances concerns over terrorism as well
as its interests in Libya's oil wealth
has put it at odds with the EU official
line there are claims it's given covert
military help to general Hoffa earlier
this week peace talks in Moscow broke
down despite many interests at stake and
the players involved Germany seems
determined to pursue its mediation role
but even if a ceasefire is agreed the
road to peace looks a long way off now
that piece just laid out the fact that
just days ago general Hefner walked away
from peace talks in Russia just days ago
so that might give some observers the
sense that there's very little
confidence you should have that a
resolution will be reached today well at
the same time we have to say that just
on the eve of these talks general hafta
and his supporters blocked the exports
of oil from Libya and occupied some
Libyan oil fields again a kind of power
play on the part of the generals showing
how powerful he is how he is able in
fact a cut of the lifeline for the whole
of Libya the oil income is important
both for his side and for the
internationally recognized government on
the other hand the German Foreign
Minister has recently been to see in
general after in Libya and came back
saying after is prepared to accede to
the cessation of hostilities that has in
fact been arranged at the moment and
possibly to a ceasefire so it's very
unclear how far this is going to go in
fact general huffner and his opposite
number as it were fired outside the
a leader of the internationally
recognized government not literally
sitting at the table today they're
staying in the background it's their
back as the people who actually are
responsible for the arms coming in for
the mercenaries coming in that are going
to have to thrash it out amongst
themselves hunts whenever there are a
high-stakes diplomacy like in this case
with emotions running high really
intense war in fact factions the
question is if there's a resolution
assuming there is one
will that resolution actually have teeth
what effect will it will it actually
have on the ground how likely is that to
really matter in this case or is it just
going to end up being a piece of paper
and that's absolutely crucial it could
just end up being a piece of paper after
all we've had an United Nations imposed
arms embargo for years and arms have
been flowing into Libya Libya in huge
numbers that piece of paper stayed just
a piece of paper so the question of how
this is going to be implement is is
going to be crucial the kind of
discussions that are going on foresee
some sort of role for the United Nations
al-fayed Esaias has said that he wants a
European Union forced to come into Libya
to sea to oversee the transition period
there is some possibility of some kind
of military observer mission on the part
of the United Nations being established
but that's all very unclear at the
moment and as you say that is crucial
how is this going to be implemented even
if there's an agreement today you
mentioned the United Nations so let's
stick with this notion of reaching
resolution which is crucial at this
point the UN has says that they want to
make sure that there is no more foreign
interference and yet when you look at
the layer the red land out there in
Berlin today it is full of foreign
players those are going to be the main
negotiators is there going to be some
room for compromise yes there's always
room for compromise obviously it's a
matter of power it's a matter of finding
a balance between the various interests
interests that are represented by these
powers with their interest involved in
things like oil things like migration
and terrorism a division of influence in
the Mediterranean area all of that plays
roles geo-strategically very
and these major players have to agree on
what the division of power division of
interests they could see in happening in
the future if they agree then the the
competence on the ground will have to
stick with airline DW political
correspondent Hans Braun's thanks so
much